[Music starts] [Michael F. Chiang, MD]
I'm an ophthalmologist by background
and I actually started my career
in 2001 at Columbia University
[Audio Description - not captioned]
as an NLM postdoctoral fellow. And since
then, I've spent 20 years in academia as a
clinician scientist working at the interface
of ophthalmology and biomedical informatics.
In November 2020, I started a new job at NIH
as director of the National Eye Institute.
And I'm really excited to be a investigator here
at the National Library of Medicine because,
you know in a way, it's what
I started my career doing.
At the National Eye Institute, our
mission is to eliminate vision loss
and improve quality of life through vision
research, and that's an application domain.
And at the National Library of Medicine,
what we do is methodological research
in biomedical informatics and data science.
And I think it's really important to
connect the methodology with the application.
One of the things that I do is I
develop artificial intelligencemethods
to diagnose a pediatric retinal
disease called retinopathy of prematurity.
It's one of the leading causes of
blindness in babies around the world.
Stevie Wonder is someone who went blind from ROP
in the 1950s before there was a treatment for it.
And we've developed an AI system that
received FDA breakthrough status.
And one of the things that we've been
doing is trying to find ways to apply
AI to real world problems in eye care for kids.
Babies who are premature, and therefore
at risk for retinopathy of prematurity,
come disproportionately from urban
and rural medically underserved areas.
And there are huge challenges
in terms of delivering eye care,
and health care overall, to those babies.
And so, one of the things that I did at
the very beginning of my career is that
we work to develop and validate telemedicine
systems for retinopathy of prematurity diagnosis.
And now, what we're starting to
do is to experiment with - can
we implement AI, artificial intelligence, into those
telemedicine systems to be able
to improve the accuracy and the
quality of the diagnosis that
we're able to make remotely.
There's never been a time in history where
we've had so much access to science and
technology as being applied to healthcare. And
I think one of the challenges for the future is
how to move things like biomedical informatics and
artificial intelligence and data science
into the mainstream of healthcare.
[Music continues]
[Music fades to silence]
[Silence]